parece naval y sabía lo que se exponía y
los peores pronósticos se han cumplido
ha sido detenido en el propio control de
pasaportes del aeropuerto ruso de ser
emitido después de un día en el que las
autoridades rusas se han tenido que
esforzar para separar a naval ni de sus
seguidores han detenido a decenas de
manifestantes en la terminal del
aeropuerto de vnúkovo pero también han
tenido que intervenir en el cielo porque
casi en el último minuto han desviado el
vuelo de naval ni para que aterrizar se
en otro aeropuerto de la capital rusa y
no pudiese así darse un baño de masas
que le espera ahora naval y pues
seguramente una condena de cárcel pero
además esta vez de cárcel real hasta la
fecha venía cumpliendo un régimen
abierto pero técnicamente obvio porque
debido a su hospitalización en alemania
no ha podido presentarse periódicamente
ante las autoridades sanitarias